of the hour according to the task news
agency in Russia one person has been
killed and 16 we understand to be
injured after an explosion in a cafe in
Russia's Second City of Saint Petersburg
this appears to have been confirmed now
by the Russian defense Ministry in the
interior Ministry in fact the equivalent
of our home office one person has been
killed and this person is now according
to the ministry was a Russian military
blogger killed in the explosion in a
cafe in Saint Petersburg
and 16 wounded let's turn to retired Air
bias Marshall Sean belter of course a
developing Story the interior Ministry
in Russia has now confirmed that this
has happened in a cafe your thoughts
yeah we would literally pick up the
details at the moment as you say
was The prominent Pro Putin blogger had
over half a million followers on
telegram he died in the explosion it was
15 now it's 16 injured posts on his blog
appeared only three and a half hours ago
um the Russia suggests already that
there were 200 over 200 grams of TNT
used in the explosion that's a lot of
detail for this early after the thing if
we look at why what caused the explosion
it could have been Ukrainian military
they have been doing attacking airfields
behind Russian lines but that looks
really unlikely it to be attacking the
middle of a city and this isn't really a
military Target but it could have been
the resistance movement much more likely
as rising Russian casualties from the
war in Ukraine there's increasing
domestic unrest back at home and this is
this blogger was a very public face a
very public supporter of Putin but I
would urge caution at the moment we just
don't know enough details at the moment
but we'll bring them when we got them of
course